à
doté d'un casque d'un gant et d'une
batte ils sont 14 à s'entraîner à cette
nouvelle discipline sportive de baseball
moi j'avais déjà commencé à mettre en
place sur la du baseball mois l'activité
me plaît beaucoup et les élèves
joaillier cuba il adhérait pas mal donc
moi je trouvais que c'était plutôt
intéressant qui ont à rob est difficile
à l'installation de très bonne qualité
qui fait partie des meilleurs stades de
france de baseball le collège va ouvrir
à la rentrée 2022 une nouvelle section
sportive les collégiens auront ainsi
quatre heures de baseball par semaine en
plus de l'ess le mercredi après midi
leur emploi du temps sera alors aménagé
pour qu'ils puissent suivre les
entraînements et pour conclure cette
année ils affrontaient les cougars de
montigny
[Musique]
au début c'était mon coeur qui faisait
des baies du baseball et avant je
faisais du foot donc il m'a dit si tu
veux tu peux faire du baseball pour
essayer si tu aimes bien que je continue
mais vu que j'adore maintenant je
continue on va dire que c'est un sport
qui change c'est hors du commun il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de règles il ya
beaucoup de choses à réfléchir c'est un
sport autant individuel que collectif
donc je pense que ce soit qu'il ya sur
le jeu cette nouvelle section sportive
est ouverte aux enfants allant de la 6e
à la 3e tous niveaux confondus